he's tall thin faceless and wears a dark
suit once he's in your life you're
doomed if you try to learn more about
him or even think about him it only
makes it easier for him to find you
he's the notorious internet monster
Slenderman this 21st century monster
gained popularity as more and more
content was created and shared about him
enough so that he jumped the digital
border and began to infiltrate other
media video games comic books and movies
show him stalking humans people also
dress up like him and hunt for him in
the woods
then there's the tragic attempted murder
of a 12 year old girl in 2014 that made
him a household name unlike so many
other monsters we know exactly when this
one was created and by whom a rarity
made possible by the internet his
obscurity is what makes him scary but
the real impact of this monster is how
he changed folklore forever
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
on June 8th 2009 the online forums
something awful posted a Photoshop
challenge turn ordinary photographs into
creepy looking images through digital
manipulation user Victor's surged whose
real name is Eric Knudsen responded on
June 10th with two black-and-white
photographs the first photograph shows a
group of teenagers walking towards the
camera behind them you can barely make
out at all blurry figure lurking in the
background the teen seemed unaware of
his presence the second photograph
depicts a more clear image of Slender
Man
it shows children happily playing in a
playground but in the background under a
tree a shadowy figure moves in this
photo
it appears that Slender Man also has
tentacles and almost overnight
Slenderman became an internet sensation
as his mythos evolved some common traits
emerged Slender Man is described as
noticeably taller than the average human
with an oddly proportioned body
he's very thin with long arms and legs
and in some accounts he can sprout
tentacles from his back he wears a suit
and has no facial features or hair and
is unnatural
anyone who sees Slenderman is then
stalked by him so it becomes a sort of
creepy loop the more he is seen the more
commonly he appears so the fact that I'm
making this video means I'm already
doomed
what made Victor surges posts stand out
more than other submissions was that it
was the first to create a narrative that
accompanied the images he posted the
photos with the following text one of
two recovered photographs from the
Stirling city library blaze notable for
being taken the day which 14 children
vanished and for what is referred to as
the Slenderman deformity cited as film
defects by officials fire at library
occured one week later actual photograph
confiscated as evidence
1986 photographer Mary Thomas missing
since June 13 1986 Slenderman was born
from those words the context crafted the
myth Something Awful users instantly
latched on to the mysterious monsters
story the Slender Man post sparked
enthusiastic comments with many noting
how it would make for great TV show or
book others quickly jumped onto the
Slenderman bandwagon by posting their
own accounts of the creature within days
the thread became almost exclusively
made up of real Slenderman legends one
notable post from a user with screen
names see gars mentions his own
investigation into a film project that
caused his friend to become increasingly
disturbed a few days later the film
project in question was uploaded to
YouTube under the title Marble Hornets
if he was a story inspired by Slenderman
about a boogeyman figure capable of
distorting audio and visual recordings
causing the film's creator to
insane it turned out that CG gars was
Troy Wagner who crafted the series with
his friends Marble Hornets became a huge
part of the Fosters mythos and was
incredibly successful totally more than
90 found-footage episodes it even helped
inspire two Slender Man video games
Slender Man made his creepypasta debut
on January 14 2010 creepypasta developed
as a place to collect spooky stories
users would copy and paste creepy texts
from other websites such as Fortune some
people argue that creepypasta and other
web pages such as the no-sleep subreddit
obscure the truth they are veiled behind
a faux authenticity fictional stories
often accompanied by seemingly authentic
images that are treated as real but as a
scholar of the Gothic I can tell you
that treating mythical stories as actual
accounts is nothing new at all
some original gothic novels were
published and falsely advertised as
translations of newly discovered
manuscripts by real authors or alongside
claims that they were true counts from
some anonymous writer but in reality
they were completely fabricated more
recently found footage horror films are
another example of how the lines of
fiction and truth are intentionally
blurred
Victor Serge admits Slenderman was made
up an idea he crafted from all the
things that scare him with the name he
says he thought up on the fly he does
admit he used the tall man in the
phantasm films as the source material
for the first Slender Man images but by
keeping the details vague he allowed
others to fill in the gaps of his
creation with their own fears Slender
Man shares similarities to a lot of
pre-existing characters he's been
compared to the Pied Piper Buffy the
Vampire Slayer's the gentleman the
silence from Doctor Who
the men in black and Jack Skellington
tales about him contains some elements
of the Blair Witch Project and HP
Lovecraft stories there's even a
pre-existing Japanese yokai that appears
human but has no facial features just
like Slenderman you may have heard that
Slender Man sightings have been
happening for hundreds of years that he
appears in old texts and art from
Germanic mythology to Canadian folklore
Norse mythology and Egyptian
hieroglyphics it's enticing to think
that we can discover a monster that's
been secretly haunting us for years
that's a cool story but none of that is
true he didn't exist before 2009 take
this image for example some people claim
this is an image of Slenderman dating
back to the 16th century but in reality
it's a photoshopped image based on
existing prints from that time period
the original comes from a series of
Danse Macabre images meant to show that
death is universal this one another
Photoshop of an image taken from the
same artist similar to other monsters
such as Windigo and Tokoloshe Slender
Man has been used as a scapegoat for
deviant behavior in 2014 two girls
attempted to murder their friend because
they allegedly thought it would attract
the attention of Slenderman such a
dramatic and violent crime drew the
attention of the media and the once
notorious internet monster became a
familiar story offline as well causing
moral panic and
dear son demands tasteless features
allow us to transcribe pretty much any
of our fears onto him he's uncanny his
human silhouette and common clothing
make him familiar but something is off
his dark suit is unsettling there could
be a couple of reasons why it shows him
polished and put together and
intentional in what he does he is
self-aware patiently waiting and
watching his victims there's also the
association of black suits with death
something we commonly see at funerals
and then there's the idea that the suit
symbolizes power and authority it's
anonymous and timeless the idea that
Slenderman specifically targets children
feeds into our fear that there are evil
strangers ready to kidnap our kids
slender man's the new version of don't
take candy from a stranger a lesson that
keeps kids safe by instilling a healthy
wariness for adults they don't know
Slenderman is always watching you even
if you don't know it this parallels are
more legitimate fears of being
constantly watched by cameras and other
technologies that monitor our day-to-day
actions heck even the Internet where
Slenderman was first created constantly
logged so much of what we do
Sunda man takes the fear of something
that seems abstract like a story on the
internet to something more concrete like
a man outside your window at night
Slenderman could have been nothing more
than a scary made-up story but when
people Miss Rita treated as real the
lines between what is authentic and what
is false blurred to dangerous levels
technology allows anyone to make fake
things appear real photoshopped images
computer edited video footage and
falsified documents can spread quickly
and are seen as legitimate and anyone
can contribute thunderman represents an
important shift in folklore where myths
are crafted at a blistering pace across
social cultural and physical boundaries
it's a kind of digital gothic where the
haunted house becomes the haunted
everything Slender Man and other digital
folklore succeeds because of the
Internet these myths spread like
wildfire through social media the time
stamps of online folklore allow us to
examine real time discussions responses
and reactions to mythology as its
created it gives us an exact account of
how the story developed in real time
something that didn't exist in
traditional folklore studies before I
think this is part of what makes
Slenderman so popular what gives him
life he can be made by anyone for anyone
Slenderman unintentionally
revolutionized how horror stories are
told
he opened up the doors for anyone with
an internet connection to help create a
legend oh I hear the kids sorry
it's literally great I know I want to
see okay perfect